[Music]
hello how is everyone doing today this
is Pete here from Lords of gaming dotnet
iron Lords podcast and I'm here with
several inverts I see you at the arcade
true and REM you and I'm gonna show you
today young Souls a game by one p2p
studio from the north of France
hi guys and I hope you like it sounds
great so yes we are here playing young
souls and we're gonna go check out some
gameplay so I want you to tell us a
little bit about you know your
development team while this is starting
up a little here so basically young
Souls is a game made by 1 P 2 P which is
like studio from the lots of friends
it's the story of two orphan orphan
twins Tristan and Jen they're kind of
outcasts in their city but they've been
adapted by a like kind of old scientist
that's kind of their adopted adopted
father the beginning of the game is kind
of a flash forward but basically at some
point they come home and they're out of
the fuzzer disappeared and they discover
that behind this kind of office there is
like a secret room that goes to a
basement where there's a portal to the
goblins world and so they go on a quest
to kind of search further adapted father
and kind of discover what's all about
with the goblin world and what why they
want to go to war with humans excellent
answer and this animation looks really
really really really like really smooth
and beautiful so what type of entropy
you guys using for this this is unity
okay so you okay
animation is is made using a flash but
it's just like the tool being used
because it makes it easier you'll see
there are lots of different gears lots
of different customization elements but
as you can see it looks very smooth
doesn't look like a flash animation
basically but it's a great tool they
used and they they've been used to use
that tool for a very long time
no really know how to like use it to the
best of like the possibilities and but
it's also 3d so it's a mix between 2d
and 3d as you can see so you adds depth
to the to the kind of backgrounds and at
the same time you have this very you
know like animation and graphics with
lots of character lots of personality
but you can only have with 2d basically
I love how they I love first of all
co-op games cuz you know I play with my
brother all the time doing stuff and and
you know coming from you know playing
lots of games when when we were younger
and seeing a game like this it fully
pulls me in and draws me in and this is
the way that this was done I love it
because I love how it shows you know
that that separation of character and
the background it looks really really
nice so um so it's just coming out for
what platforms are we in an island city
platform its if the game is coming out
this year and we'll make some more
announcements in there probably by the
end of summer we'll make some big
announcement about the game and more
Precision's about the platforms and
everything so I see that this is this
level base how does this work now
because I see like you know numbers next
to each character basically this is just
the introduction of the game where you
can have learned the basic mechanics of
the game the core gameplay is a kind of
a beat em up game with RPG mechanics so
basically you have a night and day cycle
during the day you you like hang out in
the city I go to different shops buy
some clothes do some exercise at the gym
do some turn up boxing tournaments meet
some NPCs and veel some aspects of the
stories in the human world meets with
lots of different characters and stuff
like that and then when you're ready at
nights you'll go back home you'll go to
the basement go through the portal and
enter different dungeons that's that's
really cool now the exact kind of makes
me think of I think it was called
punch no yeah you know you know what I'm
talking about so yes there's this I can
go you can work out your character
during the daytime and then right after
that you end up going right after doing
like your whatever you need to do also
what's cool is that because it's a night
and day cycle it's also calendar based
so basically every night and day cycle
is going to be a different day so one
day you go to the city some some shops
will be closed because today they closed
some NPCs will be there some days and
not the others do your relationship with
them will evolve as well in the city and
then at night when you go to the
dungeons we'll see a bit later basically
you you unveil the story you go through
dungeons you beat minibuses big buses
your different rooms different types of
gameplay and then you progress and every
time you go into a dungeon you kind of
like use this machine to go there but
then like at some point at night you
can't go like as much as you want
you have to stop go back to sleep gain
some experience increase your stats
during the day go a bit to the city
train and then go back at night and do
it all over again and you progress like
that like bit by bit so it looks like
right now the characters both have
swords and shields is there a plan for
doing other types of weapons or there
are they are already there are already
lots and lots of weapons you have
daggers sword and shield a bow and arrow
double hand sword daggers what else you
have grappling hook mind grandpa those
revenues yes I love those so um is there
only two characters that you can play us
throughout this whole time yes it's
really a story based game so the game is
written by Matthew reader
we used to work at tail tail on the
walking dead and also like world as a
writer direct writing director for them
vampyre last game from yes so all the
dialogues all the story super important
and the personality of each twin
develops along the game as well you see
there the relation of the relationship
that between each other they have their
own personality their relationship with
their adoptive father as well their
relationship with the whole NPC's in the
city so yeah that's why like the fact
that they're both of them is really
important even when you play by yourself
there is an AI that follows you so
you're never alone basically it's always
the twins like fighting together yes yes
well nothing says you know more type of
you know cohesion of two people then
like you know twins cuz you know they're
essentially one person you know there's
somebody that's really really neat
that's really cool so do you um do you
have any like showing of how you can
show us like the that skill trees or
anything you're saying for now there
will be in the the final game this demo
is kind of odd actually it's 8 8 to 9
months old so the game evolved a lot
since then but it kind of gets you like
the whole feeling out around the game
you can see right there for example
that's every day when you wake up you
can choose your ear does your cheese's
review matter that doesn't matter that's
for the day that for you put doubt you
have so many possibilities they share
the same wardrobe you know like so I
it's like you can really have fun you
know you have hats we have shoes you
have pretty much anything and at night
you'll see we're going to go to the
dentures after that and so you'll see a
bit how it goes yeah so you can press B
to select when your monster
we're gonna go downstairs so what right
now we're in dimension where like we're
used to live your adoptive father and
right now it's a bit after the
introduction while you discover that he
disappeared you went to the office and
behind the office you saw that strange
room with an elevator that goes down to
the basement and leads to a portal room
every you know family member has that
elevator in the back of the you know
office you know what I'm saying so every
time you take the elevator it brings you
to the net to the nighttime time of the
game okay so I want to see how that you
know your equip your gear here you know
when you're ready is enough that's what
I want to show you now you're saying
that you only have a couple of people
working on your team so the development
team is the core team of two people now
therefore full time working on the game
so let's see the gear so basically we
share the gear as well so you have
daggers like double double and swerd
single hand sword and you donate here
you can't she like share the gear only
one person get that he's wasn't
you have shields different types of
shields that's cool helmets different
hell and each of them have different
stats on it and weight different stats
and it looks like your speed actually
depends upon what weapon and gear you're
wearing the weight of your of your armor
of your weapons and also like the
resistant to certain elements the
efficiency against certain elements
because your elemental damage is
incorporated in us yes because like
every dungeons are within like there are
big chapters in the game each chapter is
at different biomes who have eyes fire
jungle and each biome has specific
enemies so you need to gear up
accordingly because once you're in the
dungeon you can't gear up anymore so how
many how many different types of levels
routes say there are like tons or is it
like dungeon based and fifty dungeons
the game length is around like a bit
more than 40 hours so so are each
dungeon which says this is placeholder
UI right so but you get the idea
so those are all kinds of different
biomes right in each biome we'll have
like kind of mandatory dungeon that you
have to go through but then you have
some kind of hubs like that but you're
not obliged to do everything as long as
you do the main path you can go there
and not do these dungeons right right
but the more you progress the harder the
level will get right so sometimes you
can code to go back and do certain
dungeons so that you couldn't do when
you were at entering that room so
there's like lots of replayability you
know
and you can choose whatever order you
choose to do the dungeons each dungeons
will bring your new gear experience
access to other dungeons access to new
skills all that kind of stuff can you
show us another biome so oh I don't want
to spoil it oh but you have to do this
second first biome and this is the jails
couple inches because that's where
you're going to search first to get to
know where your adoptive father is
basically where we're at because you're
guessing like he's in jail with the
goblins right so that's the first level
of the of the jails so I think our gear
is a bit overpowered for that level but
that does give you a good idea of how
the level works and everything excellent
so now this is where the leveling system
kind of comes into play because it's
actually the gameplay itself interesting
now let's see how the characters are
with you know with the daggers you are
moving a lot faster than you are with
the Ender with the sword and shield
that's that's really nice it makes it
really you have a good replayability if
you say because you don't know you know
interesting is kind of different
exactly and so many combinations as well
you know that you can basically like try
daggers and heavy ever for example you
know you can try like double hand sword
with like like rogue like leather armor
or something like that you know there's
also like barehanded fighting that you
can learn in the city like in a boxing
club you know that's nice that's cool
excellent okay so we're gonna we're
gonna kind of go through this a little
bit longer but I want to say thank you
very much for taking some time she kind
of showing us you know young Souls here
I'm I'm loving this this is great I love
this type of game I will play them all
day long so I appreciate your time thank
you very much right Lords game without
net check this out see you later
[Music]